[MUSIC PLAYING]
CORRIE ELSTON: Hi.
Good afternoon.
Almost the end of day two
and I hope everybody's
had a brilliant day so far.
Welcome.
Thank you for making time to
come to this presentation.
My name is Corrie Elston.
I'm a solutions architect
with Google Cloud Platform.
Now, the title of my
presentation today
is securing and managing
your big data environment,
which is a broad title--
in fact, an enormously
broad title.
We could be here until
this time tomorrow
talking through all
the possibilities
in this area, which has
pluses and minuses to it.
Plus side is that I love talking
to people and presenting.
So I'd be quite happy to go on
through the night and do this.
The minus side, of
course, is that you'd
miss out on the festivities
in San Francisco this evening
and there's a load of
other good presentations
that you're going
to want to see.
So if I weigh the
pluses and minuses,
my needs versus your needs, then
clearly we should stay strictly
to the hour that we've got.
And if we're going
to stay to the hour,
we should set the scene
and exchange some context
about what we're
going to talk about.
First of all,
securing and managing.
What I really mean by this
is what will you take away
from this presentation?
What concrete, actionable,
useful information
can I give to you in an hour?
First step-- one
of the pleasures
of being a solutions
architect at Google
is I get to work
with enterprises
of all shapes, sizes, and
kinds from the very largest
to the very smallest, to the
oldest and most established,
to the brand new in a variety
of different industries.
And I'm only one person.
I'm part of a team where there
are tens and tens of people
doing the same sort of thing.
There are many other
teams doing similar jobs.
So this presentation is
a collation, filtering,
and aggregation of
all of the things
that these people have learned.
You will get from
this presentation
a set of best practices
for securing and managing
a big data and machine
intelligence environment that
have been hardened in
production and represent
a practical,
pragmatic, proper way
to go about managing and
securing an environment that
has been used across a
variety of organizations
and industries.
The best practices
will cover helping
you secure your
environment, helping
to address and mitigate an
existential threat to what
we do.
A security incident at any
point in time is dreadful.
It can take your data,
your IP, your code,
can reduce a hard earned
reputation to rubble in no time
flat-- so something
to be avoided.
An aside on security
at this point,
Google Cloud Platform takes
care of many security concerns
on your behalf by default. It
takes care of a lot for you
without you having
to do anything.
We have a team of over 700
technologists working full time
to make GCP more
secure, Google more
secure, and the whole
of technology better
for everybody.
But there are some
parts of security
that require your attention.
Take, for example, your data.
And of course, some
of your data is
going to be incredibly
private to a few people
within your company even--
some to teams, some to
parts of the organization,
some you'll want to make public.
So you're going to have to think
about how you configure access
control in each of those cases.
The access control
mechanism exists.
You're going to have
to configure it.
And that's what we're
thinking about and talking
about in this presentation.
It's not the broad realm
of fundamental security.
I'm sure you've seen some
wonderful, insightful
presentations already
today and then
going into tomorrow about that.
We are talking about your
specific requirements and use
cases and how we address those.
Help you grow quickly--
any time that you
spend administering
your systems is time
that you're not spending
on your unique value add.
Now Google Cloud Platform
makes it relatively easy
to administer things.
We try and pay down that
effort on your behalf.
But still, there
is effort involved.
Now, as you go forward
and you're growing,
and you're growing
hopefully very quickly,
that administrative overhead
can become significant.
You don't want to
be doing that stuff.
We'll try and help you.
These practices will help
you enormously pay that down.
Help reduce stress--
an oft overlooked
but I think incredibly
important part of what we all do
is to reduce the
amount of stress.
These practices will help people
to move quickly, fail quickly,
succeed, and they help
to address situations
whereby you and me are sitting
at a computer wondering
what's going to happen
if we execute this SQL
or if we delete this VM.
Is it going to
affect the group--
the people that are working
on lifetime value over there,
is it going to hose what they're
doing and so on and so forth.
We've all been in
that situation.
We've all hated it.
We never want to go there again.
And for future
generations, we certainly
don't want to keep that
style of behavior going.
So it helps you in
all of those ways.
Your-- who are you in the
context of this presentation?
Well, you're somebody that wants
to use the technologies that we
have in the cloud, all of those
great analytics and machine
learning tools.
You want to build and create
and heroically sort of charge
into data and make
things happen.
And that's awesome and
that applies to all of us
in some way, shape, or form.
So we'll do just a little
bit better than that.
You are not necessarily
an individual.
If you're starting off
and looking at code labs,
and you should go down
to the first floor
and look at the code labs
because I was blown away
by how good they are--
solutions, tutorials,
those things--
this presentation will
be interesting for you
but it's not squarely
on your critical path.
But it's interesting for
you because you never know.
You're obviously investigating
with an aim in mind.
Neither are you part of
an enormous organization
that already has infrastructure
teams and security teams.
Again, this will be interesting
and somewhat insightful
for you, but it's not squarely
in your bull's eye either.
As an aside, the
conversations-- if any of you
are part of those
enormous organizations,
we have a slightly different
style of conversation.
It's about integrating the
technologies I talk about today
with preexisting technologies
that you already have.
Happy to do that if anybody
outside of the presentation
wants to talk about it.
No, essentially,
you're everybody else--
small enterprises,
medium sized enterprises,
teams within larger
enterprise growing quickly
in size or in reputation
or in influence.
You're the next big thing
that's coming along.
A big data
environment-- what does
a-- actually, what does your
big data environment look like?
Here's a premised
architecture for big data
and machine learning--
Google's tools that we're
exposing in the cloud.
They're all wonderful.
They're all highly
value additive
and we're very proud of them.
But this is not the focus
of the presentation today.
You're going to use
some variation of this
that's appropriate to your use
cases and your requirements.
Again, outside of
this presentation,
if you want to talk about this
in the context of what you're
doing, [INAUDIBLE] out there.
You have the tree houses, all
the booths, a wonderful place
to grab Googlers.
I'd be happy to do that.
We want to talk about imagine
this is your architecture,
this architecture in the
context of your organization.
And what I mean by
that is that typically,
you don't have one
system, maybe not
even one version of a system.
You certainly don't have
one individual user.
You have a variety of
users with disparate skill
sets, disparate
sets of expertise,
and they're all
hitting your systems.
You typically don't
even have one system.
You have lots.
You have the
lifetime value team.
recommendation engine team.
In banking-- I used to
work in foreign exchange.
You have that team.
You have commodities, credit,
and you have all sorts going on
and dev and test and everything.
And that's what we're
trying to address--
managing that such that it is
secure, transparent, and easy
to administer.
To establish a hook
to hang our hats on,
it's useful to talk
about an example.
For anybody that knows me--
actually, for all of you.
For the people
that don't know me,
I have a long financial
background before this.
So I'm going to talk
about a financial example
and I'm going to call it
Example because naming things is
super, super hard.
Example is a small
growing financial services
company that's doing novel
research into financial data.
It looks at foreign exchange,
the exchange of two currencies
at an agreed rate, and it looks
at equities, buying and selling
shares.
Rigorously focused on
doing the right thing,
so even now, it has a
compliance department
that oversees everything
that's going on.
It's interested in the Asian
markets for foreign exchange.
So it has an Asian portfolio.
The US markets for equities--
it has a US portfolio.
And that's Example.
It's something that you can all
identify with and it resonates
and you can see
how it scales out.
You're growing.
Example is growing.
You have more
departments coming in.
You certainly have more
interest and more projects
and it will grow both depth-wise
and horizontally as well.
A quick checkpoint-- we know
what we're trying to achieve,
security, ease of administration
and minimal stress.
You're in the broad
middle of the spectrum.
Your systems have
multiple users all with
different requirements.
You have multiple systems and
you're growing, potentially
growing rapidly.
So what we're
going to do next is
we're going to overlay the
two concepts that we have.
We have a premised architecture.
We have Example.
Let's do this mentally
to start with.
Now, first of all,
you have users.
I'm going to second myself
into example for the purposes
of this presentation.
You have Corrie at example.com.
We have Bjergsen.
We have Keane.
We have Froggen. We have Impact.
We have all these
people at example.com,
and those people play
that variety of roles.
Some of them merely
want to view data.
Some of them are analysts
that are doing our analysis
of machine learning.
Some of them are
administrators that
are building the whole thing.
And we have expectations of
those roles, expectations
of the rights that
they have-- those
of a viewer, those of an editor,
those of an administrator.
And of course, you have
the underlying resources--
BigQuery, Cloud
SQL, Cloud Spanner,
and so on and so forth.
All of that information
leads us to a separation
of concerns that then drives our
design into the technologies.
You have users and groups.
Now, a user is
essentially an identity.
It identifies who somebody is.
Group is a collection of users
that also has an identity.
And we administer and
manage these in G Suite.
There are other alternatives,
but I happen to prefer G Suite.
I think it's a
great set of tools.
We have roles and
we have resources.
Resources we just referred to.
It's all the stuff that we
want to use in Google Cloud
Platform.
Roles are the glue that
brings it together.
Roles allow us to answer
questions such as,
can Bjergsen, who is a
member of our FX analyst
group at Example, create
a table in BigQuery?
And the answer should be yes.
Can Corrie, who is also
a member of FX analysts,
delete an equities project?
And the answer should be
willingly or unwillingly,
accidentally or not, no.
So now let's have a
look at the technologies
that we're going to use.
G Suite-- I'm not going to
dwell on this one very much.
I've used it quite extensively
over the last year or so--
intuitive, easy to
use, and I loved it.
G Suite admin console
allows you to manipulate
security and users.
Google Groups allows you
to manipulate groups.
Best practices is about
all we'll do here.
Fully managed users-- you can
create, suspend, and delete
users such that when something
becomes apparent to you
as an administrator or
to your administrator,
they can stop people accessing
your systems immediately.
Password strength--
inside of G Suite,
you can both monitor and
enforce password strength,
and strong passwords are good.
Two factor
authentication-- again,
you can monitor and
administer and enforce the use
of two factor authentication.
Now those things,
most likely, you
regard most of that as
common sense and so do I.
And that's great.
But actually, it pays down a
huge threat to your systems.
To be able to have an
elevated and increased level
of confidence that the
person using your systems
is who they say they are
and who you think they are
is just great.
It helps enormously
pay down a threat.
Somebody has to know something--
username and password--
as well as having
something-- the token
for two factor authentication.
And our last best
practice is that we do not
allow open enrollment to groups
that we use for roles in GCP.
We'll go through that a bit
more, but it makes sense.
If we are using groups to
somehow control access to GCP
and we allow anybody
to join any group,
then we've achieved
nothing whatsoever.
Technologies in Google
Cloud Platform--
Cloud Resource Manager
we'll go through first.
Cloud Resource Manager is a--
who here went to the earlier
session on Cloud Resource
Manager?
Then I have a treat for you.
Cloud resource manager
is a great idea.
It's a relatively
simple concept.
And what it does is it
provides a mechanism
for grouping and hierarchically
organizing resources.
Now, what I mean by
that is the following.
A resource is owned by a
single project with any access,
but for resources
between projects
having to be
specifically set up.
Now what was introduced
earlier on in the day
is that you can organize
projects into folders.
And you can nest
folders within folders.
And then at the top
level, your organization
owns folders and projects.
And GCP sits over the
top of all of that.
And the powerful
concept there is
that once you have this in place
and you can decompose and model
your organization
within it, you can
start to operate above
the level of projects.
You can apply things like
permissions to folders.
You can view all
of the permissions
and all of the
projects that you've
got from your organization.
Let's think of this in
the context of Example.
As a G Suite customer,
Example already
has an organizational node
when it first gets into GCP.
Otherwise, you can simply ask
for one and you'll get one.
Underneath that, we
have FX, Compliance,
and Equities folders.
Underneath those folders,
we create projects
for the Asian portfolio
and the US portfolio,
and also for compliance,
because although they're just
looking over what
we're doing, they will
want to do their own analysis.
And underneath those, they
have their own resources.
A question that came up a lot,
that comes up, but particularly
came up in the past a
lot, was how do people
control the proliferation
of stuff in GCP?
And usually, what they were
talking about is projects.
Because people had-- with
the best intentions in mind,
people knew that projects were
a good entity, a good trust
boundary to model
what they were doing.
And yet they didn't want
that administration overhead
to scale with the number
of projects that they had.
Now, the answer to
that question now,
with Cloud Resource
Manager in place,
is that you don't have anything
to worry about anymore.
Embrace a proliferation
of projects
because it's your friend.
It is the right place to have a
trust boundary about resources.
And now with folders
in place, you
can begin to operate at
higher levels of abstraction
than simply projects so that the
administration overhead is not
going to scale with projects.
Second technology we'll
make a lot of use of
is Identity and
Access Management--
Cloud IAM.
Now what Cloud IAM does is
it's a way for administrators
to specify how identities
can interact with resources.
I'll explain the
concepts here together
with the example
at the same time.
First of all, you
have identities.
You have users.
You have groups.
You have service
accounts and we're
going to think about
Froggen at example.com
because he happens
to be my favorite.
And at the other end of the
spectrum, you have resources.
And in this case, we're
talking about BigQuery.
Now, a user can be given a role.
Actually, a user can be
given multiple roles,
but we'll think about this
specifically for BigQuery.
So a user has a role.
They can wear a hat.
And in this case, we want that
to be BigQuery data viewer.
Froggen can view
data in BigQuery.
A role is composed
of permissions.
It's a collection of
lower level permissions--
BigQuery data sets
list, BigQuery data
sets get, all of the things
that you would intuitively
know that a viewer of
BigQuery should have.
A policy is the
collection of all roles
that can apply to a resource--
data viewer, data owner, data
admin, all of those things
that happen.
And that chain of relationships
allows you to control how
a user, how an identity
can have a role that's
part of a policy that's
attached to a resource
and dictates how they can
interact with that resource.
We-- when I started
writing this presentation,
we were actually going
to be interested in two
different things.
Another announcement
that came very recently
means that we're going to be
interested in three things.
And it's good because it's
really additive to what
you want to do.
The first thing we're interested
in are primitive roles--
owner, editor, viewer.
These are broad,
umbrella types of role
that apply to the
whole platform.
If you are a viewer, you
can view all resources
in a GCP project.
If you are an editor, you can
create and delete resources.
If you're an owner,
you can create--
you can do anything.
You can create and
delete projects.
You can also apply
roles to people.
So you can add people in.
Those are primitive
roles and a lot of you
will be familiar with those.
IAM introduces
predefined roles, which
means that you have a lower
level, more granular way
of composing a set of roles,
such as data viewer, data
owner, data flow, developer.
You can compose different roles
into what you want your user
to be able to do.
We also now have custom roles,
which give you even more
control over what goes on.
Custom roles simplify
things in a number of ways.
You can set up--
we could create--
we, as we're building Example,
could create an analyst role.
And we can create it from
taking underlying permissions.
And quite neatly, we can also
build it off of other roles.
So we could take an existing
role and we could say, yeah,
but I don't want to do that and
I don't want them to do that
and I don't want
them to do that.
But all the rest of it is cool.
Let that go through.
Custom roles are in
an open alpha now.
You can apply to
be part of that.
Let's apply this to Example.
FX analysts at
example.com we will make
an editor of Foreign Exchange.
And I want to pause
there because I'm
using a primitive role here
just because it's easy to write.
It's just-- I'm not implying
that this is a best practice.
This is just the term that
I'll use for the slides.
And we'll go into what is
the best practice later.
Equities analyst,
editor of equities,
and compliance can view both
foreign exchange and equities
and is an editor of
its own folder, which
then means that any
projects that we
create underneath foreign
exchange, for example--
any more projects-- they
inherit the permissions
from the folder from the
hierarchy that goes above them.
One caveat to bear
in mind is that you
can get extra permissions at a
lower level in the hierarchy.
You cannot take
permissions away.
So you need to bear that in mind
as you're building things out.
But what it does
mean is that as we're
creating lots and
lots of projects,
the administrative
overhead goes down.
You already have good
solid permissions in place.
To this point, we have
organized our worlds
and we have established
trust within our worlds.
And now as the old adage
goes, we'll trust but verify.
Audit logging is
hyper important.
I find that most people, they
understand resource manager
quite quickly and
they identify with IAM
even though the devil's
in the detail with IAM.
And audit logging is sort of
something they also look at.
Audit logging is hyper
important because there's
a couple of things that
you can probably guarantee.
The one is that as we do the
best job we probably can,
it's probably going to be some
approximation of a good job.
And so you will
get things wrong.
The other thing is that
things change over time.
We're talking about a growing,
evolving enterprise and things
change over time.
Audit logging is the physics
of what goes on in your system.
Who's interacting with
resources and who's
interacting with data?
Who's creating things,
who's destroying
things, who's accessing things?
There's three
different ways that you
can look audit logging.
One of them is in the Activity
view from the console.
That is good and it is useful.
But the reason I dwell
over it a little bit
is I don't find it the most
useful way of doing it.
You can also look at it
through Stackdriver Logging.
That's what I like to do because
there, you can specify filters.
You can search by date ranges.
You can create
alerts in Stackdriver
and you can make
this truly useful.
Because what I implied before
is that you should spend--
this is hyper important.
You should spend time on this.
And yet, I'm trying to
reduce the amount of time
that you're spending
on administration.
And the way you
pay down that time
is by creating
appropriate filters,
creating appropriate
alerts, because what
you want to be working on
a forward looking basis
is exceptions
rather than looking
at everything that goes on.
The final thing that you
can do with audit logs
is you can export them to Google
Cloud Storage or to BigQuery
and you should
export them to both
and you should keep
that data forever.
Because eventually, you'll
want to investigate something.
And certainly,
you'll want to learn.
You're analysts.
You'll want to analyze that data
to see what you can do better.
Checkpoint-- Cloud
Resource Manager
defines a hierarchy,
allowing you to group
and operate on your projects
and resources effectively.
Cloud IAM allows you to
define roles and policies
and apply them to different
levels of that hierarchy
that you defined with
Cloud Resource Manager.
Cloud Audit Logging
allows you to introspect
the physics of your systems.
Let's go ahead and build it.
Part of what I want to get
across in this presentation,
because we do have to cover
a lot of ground in what we're
talking about, is I want
to lodge those technologies
in your mind so that as you go
back and you're looking at GCP,
part of what you do is you
investigate these technologies.
Part of a 20% project for
people that want to do well
is to go off and learn more,
because we'll try and make
it as easy as possible.
But the more you know,
the better you are.
So I want to, if I--
I want to try and inspire you
to learn more about these things
as I learned more
about these things.
I was in finance.
I come from a classical
quant background
and I didn't naturally
know these things.
I joined Google.
I learned about these things.
I became far better at my
job and far more useful.
Oh, so we're going
to do two things.
We're going to build
this thing and we're
going to mix up prerequisites
and steady state.
And I will try and differentiate
between the two as we go along.
First thing we do is our G Suite
administrator builds, creates,
fx-analysts@example.com,
equities-analysts,
and compliance.
And they do that
in Google Groups.
And they ensure that there's
not open enrollment to that.
And that looks pretty
straightforward
because it actually is
pretty straightforward.
I built it out and it's
pretty straightforward
to do that stuff-- one of
the obvious nice things
about G Suite.
We can see those groups.
We have three groups.
Part of my secondment is
I'm acting as the G Suite
administrator for Example.
G Suite admin console allows
us to create and manipulate
and monitor users.
And again, it's very
easy to do that.
And we've created Bjergsen
and Froggen and Impact.
And the next thing that we do is
we map those on to our groups.
And the one thing
that I'll mention here
is that the administrator
doesn't need
to be a member of the group.
I happen to be the
administrator of the group
and you can see me as a
member of the group there.
I don't need to be a
member of the group.
Because if that was
true for all groups,
then the G Suite
administrator would somehow
be a super user of
all GCP projects
and that doesn't
need to be the case.
And now we move on
to GCP and we start
to look at our
prerequisites for GCP.
The first is that
we create folders.
And our organizational
administrator
who, if you think about
our separation of concerns,
doesn't have to be the
same person as the G Suite
administrator--
can be for very small companies,
but you're pretty quickly
going to get to the point
where these two people will
be different or even
these two groups of people
will be different.
Organization administrator
creates FX, Equities,
and Compliance folders.
And you can see the
organization view here.
You can create
them in this view.
You can also see everything
you've created in that view
and it's really neat.
But it's not the only way
that you can do things on GCP.
Typically, there's always those
three ways that you can do it.
You can do it
through the console,
you can do it from
the command line,
or you can do it
through a REST API.
And it brings up an
interesting question for us
as to what's the best practice
for creating or manipulating
these things.
Should you do it
from the console?
Should you do it essentially
as a coding exercise?
I regard this as a
grayer area because when
I talked to people about
their preferences here
and then I factored
in my own preferences,
there isn't a single school
of thought about this.
I prefer to turn it
into a coding exercise
because I come-- partly because
I come from an engineering
background, partly because it's
reproducible, partly because I
can stick it in
source code control,
and partly because I can
write code that tests my code.
And I prefer it that way.
There's a
counter-argument to that
is that creating and
modeling your organizations
is a relatively static process.
You will do it.
You will evolve it, but you
will evolve it somewhat slowly.
And also, it interacts
with audit logging.
So everything that
happens in your system
is caught in an audit log.
I happen to prefer making
it a coding exercise.
But perversely in
a way, I'm actually
going to use the console going
through this presentation
because I think it's prettier.
The white and the
blue is nicer to look
than the black and the white.
So folders, prerequisites-- our
organizational administrator
then maps our groups
onto our folders--
FX analyst as an editor
of FX, equities analysts
as an editor of equities, and
compliance as a reader of FX
and equities and an
editor of compliance.
And I feel compelled to
just call out the fact
that those primitive
roles are not necessarily
the best practice.
And you can do that
through the same console.
And it makes it very
easy because you
can select multiple
entities should you want to.
So when you map
on compliance, you
can just select FX
and Equities folders
and apply the same role to both.
So it makes it pretty
straightforward.
You can look at the
IAM view as well.
So you can set it up from
the organization view.
You can look at the IAM page and
you can see what's happening.
Now that was prerequisites,
this is steady state.
Our organizational
administrator creates
our project, Asian Portfolio.
Asian Portfolio inherits that
set of permissions from FX.
That means that
fx-analysts@example.com can
create, use, delete
resources on GCP,
whereas compliance@example.com
can only view those resources.
So our project creation, and
I said be happy and embrace
proliferation of projects,
becomes really straightforward.
And there you can see
the organization view
with both projects
actually created.
Audit logging-- audit
logging, as I said before,
hyper important.
Your organizational
administrator, or actually,
somebody with a special
role, a private log viewer
role, because you
don't want audit
logs being widely available.
You want that to
be a sort of either
specialized or a filtered
experienced people.
You look at the audit logs.
You can see them there.
Stackdriver Logging UI--
you can use them there
where you will spend the
majority of your time
drilling in and filtering and
creating the right alerts.
And what you will do is export
everything to BigQuery and GCS
and keep all of
that stuff forever.
One more topic--
Access Control Lists.
Access Control Lists,
ACLs, allow you fine
grained control over
individual buckets and objects
in GCS or over data sets
in table in BigQuery.
And the reason that that
is super useful to what
you do going forward
is that you will
have a situation such as
the following coming up
quite quickly.
Within Example, our
equities group is expanding
and they're interested
in Asian markets, which
obviously means that they're
interested in exchange rates.
As they go from their home
country to the Asian markets,
they want exchange rates.
Who better to give
them a fair exchange
rate than their buddies
in the FX department?
But if I apply a role such as
a storage viewer to equities,
I'm allowing them to
look at all buckets.
I'm giving them that
ubiquitously across FX
and I don't want that.
ACLs mean that I can
specify one bucket
or I can specify one file
that I come up with daily.
So that's another useful
tool for people's arsenals.
Boom, we built out Example.
And it didn't take
long and I hope
you see that the administrative
overhead that we've
sort of incurred in our
enterprise is relatively low.
And yet, we've decomposed
it in a really sensible way.
It is secure.
It is easy to manage.
We achieved our aims in
our build of Example.
But we're not finished
because I went on and on
about it not necessarily
being a best practice
to use primitive roles.
And now I get to sort of
unburden myself about that one.
Primitive roles are
broad-reaching things.
And I wouldn't call them
legacy, but in some ways
I regard them as
legacy concepts.
They can be useful, but
my personal preference
is not to use them.
I would always use predefined
or custom roles now.
I'll give you two examples
that will sort of give voice
to my discomfort
with primitive roles.
The first is that
if I was to make
you an editor of a project,
then you can request a quota
increase as well.
And as an administrator
of the organization,
it's not totally what I want.
I'll be able to
stand in front of it
because I'll see
it in audit logging
and I'll be able to
stop it, and I'll
have an alert created for it.
But to be honest,
it would be better
if it just didn't come up.
The other example
that I'll give you--
I've completely forgotten.
You give me a minute?
It was a good example.
AUDIENCE: It's 6 o'clock.
CORRIE ELSTON: It's 6 o'clock?
It's 6 o'clock, but this is
all really all I've done.
I've manned the booths
and I've done this.
It's not like I've
really grafted today.
Nope.
I'll come back to
it in a minute.
So-- when I remember.
So primitive roles
grant broad access,
but I don't think that
you should use them.
Pre-defined roles
and custom roles
are very interesting
because essentially,
what we're talking about here is
a principle of least privilege.
And that's the best way
to view these things is
what you would like
to start off with is
absolutely no permissions.
And then the safest thing
for you and I and everybody
is if you have only
those permissions that
allow you to do your job.
It's good for you
because you can't make--
I remember.
If I make you an
editor of the project,
you can define firewall rules.
And as an analyst, I
might not-- you know,
it's something that
you might not want.
Again, stand in front of
it using audit logging.
But again, it's better if
it actually didn't come up.
Pre-defined roles would
allow you to do that.
Pre-defined roles means
that we start from nothing
and we layer on roles.
I can say that you can
administer BigQuery.
You can be a data flow
developer, all of the things
that I know you'd want to
do as an analyst, those
and only those things.
And if you ever think
of a great reason
why you'd want to
do firewall rules,
then we can have that discussion
at that point in time.
It's a conscious
decision that we take.
Custom roles are also useful
because you could address
both of my concerns by
taking the editor role
and removing the
quota administrator
and removing the ability
for networks and firewalls.
And you could build
it up that way.
You can also name things in
a way that makes more sense
to your organization.
Variation 2-- there
will be situations
where you will want, possibly,
a greater degree of control
over encryption.
Now, Google gives you--
and you've heard this--
great encryption
by default. We'll
encrypt everything
at rest and we'll
apply what Google believes to
be best practices over that.
We'll shard it.
We'll put different
keys on the shards.
We will organize those
keys into key chains
and we will rotate
those keys frequently.
So you couldn't-- the best you
can say about your encryption
practices is that they're
as good as ours are.
We regard ours as being
as good as there are
and you can do as
good as we can.
And I want to get
it across before we
go into the variations.
There may be some
regulatory requirements that
mean that you want a different
level of interaction with keys,
and there may be some aspect
of your company philosophy
that puts you in
that way as well.
And all power to you.
So cloud key
management service--
what we're doing is a fully
managed key management service
that you can integrate
into your applications
and you can create and maintain
hierarchies of keys on GCP.
It interacts with cloud
IAM and audit logging.
So you can have permissions such
that only certain people can
create keys and they can be
different from the people that
can encrypt and decrypt data.
And everything that
happens here will
go into audit logging for
you to take a look at.
Another option is
customer supplied keys.
This is where you want the
key to be in your hands
on your machines,
effectively, either because
of philosophy or because of
a regulatory requirement,
or because you have an existing
key management infrastructure
that you want to keep using.
Now, this works for Google
Compute Engine and Google Cloud
Storage.
And it's not
completely transparent
because there are
certain things.
Like, you can't upload data
to a Cloud Storage bucket
from the console and
yet use your own keys.
So it's good.
It's not completely
seamless, but it
allows you to use your own
encryption approaches there.
We request the key whenever
we need to use the key.
We use it transiently.
We never store that key.
There is a cryptographic
hash of that key stored
that can't be used, obviously,
to reconstruct the key.
So essentially,
we borrow that key
from you for a minimal
length of time,
do what you've asked us to
do, and then the key goes.
And we came quite a long
way in that presentation.
And what I wanted to achieve
was to sort of get you
into the frame of
mind that I got
into when thinking
about these things,
to introduce the technologies
that I think you should take
away and learn more about
and become far more expert
in because it's going
to help you enormously.
And a couple of those things
are recent announcements.
Custom roles are coming
out, and folders,
which really is a really prime
idea, was announced today.
Takeaways-- these set of
takeaways come best practices.
That's the sort of culmination
of everything that we've done.
Fully managed users, strong
passwords, two factor
authentication, full stop, if I
had a microphone, because those
are things that you want to do.
No open enrollment to groups--
it just makes
perfectly good sense.
You can use the console
or the command line API
for administering
organizations and IAM.
I prefer using the command
line because I can write
unit tests for what's going on.
And if you go towards using
predefined roles and custom
roles, then being
able to unit test
those things is very useful
to you going forward.
Use an organization to
centralize project and resource
administration.
Use folders to model
your organization,
grouping like projects together
by team or functional area.
Use nested folders to model
aspects of your organization
development versus production.
Something we didn't touch on
is a separation of concerns.
Folders can also help to model
a separation of concerns.
It's not hyper important
to a lot of what
I've done in data analysis,
but it is hyper important
generally.
You may want your developers
to be a different set of people
entirely.
In fact, regulations
might mean you absolutely
have to have a different set
of people entirely looking
at development and production.
Be happy with the
proliferation of projects.
It's a good thing for you.
So audit logs--
export audit logs
to BigQuery and
Google Cloud Storage
and keep them indefinitely.
Monitor your audit logs.
Create alerts where appropriate
and use this as feedback
for refactoring
folders or roles.
You can use primitive
roles, predefined roles,
or custom roles to control
access effectively.
You should use predefined
roles or custom roles.
Encryption can be refined with
cloud key management, cloud
KMS, or client supplied keys
for particular point use cases.
Don't make that your go-to.
Make that somewhere where you're
sort of pushed to on demand.
Honorable mentions from today
go to the identity aware proxy
that was released and to data
loss prevention because that's
going to be really useful.
And I didn't
include it because I
didn't think it was totally core
to what we're talking about,
but data prep is
really cool as well.
For your analysts that
are out there working--
and my day job is as an
analyst sort of working--
super important.
It's not really
management or security,
but it is as cool
as cool can be.
And with that, it's been a
pleasure and a privilege.
Thank you very
much for your time.
[MUSIC PLAYING]